BUILDING IF YOU'RE ON THE
BUSINESS PROFESSIONS AND
ECONOMIC. OH, YEAH. JUST LIKE
SPEAK IT INTO EXISTENCE. WE DO
HAVE ENOUGH SENATORS HERE FOR A
QUORUM. WE'LL GO AHEAD AND CALL
THE MEETING TO ORDER. WE ONLY
HAVE ONE QUICK BILL TO HEAR
TODAY, AND WE ARE SO LUCKY AS TO
HAVE SENATOR GENERAL ROTH, WHO
WILL PRESENT THAT BILL TODAY ON
BEHALF OF THE COMMITTEE. BUT
FIRST, LET'S CALL ROLL ASHBY
HERE. ASHBY HERE. NGUYEN HERE.
NGUYEN. HERE. ARCHULETA HERE.
ARCHULETA HERE. BECKER DODD.
EGGMAN. EGGMAN. HERE GLAZER.
MENGIBAR! MILO. GO BEARS! HERE.
O'NEILL. HERE. ROTH. ROTH HERE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. WILK.
PRESENT. WILK PRESENT. GREAT.
THANK YOU. FIGHTING ON. OH, BOY.
WHO LET THEM WEAR SPORTS GEAR?
EVERYBODY KNOWS THIS IS LIKE THE
BOOMTOWN. OKAY. SENATOR ROTH,
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR. IT'S A
PLEASURE TO. ACTUALLY, IT'S A
PRIVILEGE TO PRESENT THIS BILL
ON BEHALF OF YOU. THE BILL IS
BACK BEFORE US TO CONSIDER
SENATE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS
RATHER, THE MEASURE NOW INCLUDES
ADDITIONAL PROVISIONS THAT STEM
FROM OUR DISCUSSIONS EARLIER
THIS YEAR AND THROUGHOUT THE
PAST, MANY MONTHS AS PART OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ATHLETIC
COMMISSION SUNSET REVIEW
OVERSIGHT ENSURES FIGHTER SAFETY
BY REQUIRING ONSITE AMBULANCES
TO TRANSPORT INJURED ATHLETES AT
THE DIRECTION OF THE SUPERVISING
PHYSICIAN AND CONFORMS THE
BOXER'S PENSION FUND.
CONTRIBUTIONS TO THE PATHWAY
CREATED LAST YEAR. YOU MAY
REMEMBER FOR MIXED MARTIAL ARTS
ATHLETES, THE WORK IS TRULY
MISSION CRITICAL. THIS WORK OF
THE COMMISSION, AND WITHOUT THIS
BILL, THE COMMISSION WILL EXPIRE
ON JANUARY ONE. RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. WE HAVE ONE
WITNESS, AND I BELIEVE ANDY
FOSTER, STATE ATHLETIC
COMMISSION EXECUTIVE OFFICER.
ANDY, YOU CAN JUST DO IT FROM
OVER THERE TODAY. LESS FORMAL.
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU. THANKS FOR
BEING HERE. DID YOU BRING A
SPECIAL GUEST WITH YOU, YES,
SENATOR. MY SON, WHO HAD AN EYE
APPOINTMENT LATER THIS MORNING
IN SACRAMENTO. HE DECIDED TO
COME WITH ME. VERY GOOD.
WELCOME. WELCOME TO THE SENATE.
ALL RIGHT. NICE TO SEE YOU. OH,
BOY. IGNORE HIM. THERE'S ONE IN
EVERY CROWD, MR. FOSTER. THANK
YOU. GO AHEAD, SENATOR ASHBY,
THE AMENDMENTS WERE PART OF THE
SUNSET REVIEW AS WE ALL MET, AND
WE DISCUSSED IN THE AMBULANCE
REQUIREMENT THAT SENATOR ROTH
HAD HAD MENTIONED AND THE
INCREASE IN THE MINIMUM PAY FOR
BOXERS FROM $100 TO $200 PER
ROUND WAS PUT IN, THE PROVISION
THAT ALLOWS THE COMMISSION
THROUGH REGULATION AND
CONSULTATION WITH THE MEDICAL
ADVISORY COMMITTEE, TO ALLOW A
PATHWAY FOR PEOPLE THAT HAVE
PREVIOUSLY TESTED FOR HEPATITIS
C, BUT HAS NOW BEEN CURED OF
THAT DISEASE, PER CDC
GUIDELINES. IT PROVIDES A
PATHWAY FOR THEM TO NOW BE
LICENSED IN THE FUTURE. ONCE THE
REGULATIONS ARE ARE IN PLACE. IT
INCREASES THE CAP ON THE BOXER'S
PENSION FUND FROM $4600 TO
$10,000, AND IT INCREASES THE
ASSESSMENT ON THE TICKETS FROM
$0.88 TO $1 TO MATCH THE MIXED
MARTIAL ARTS THAT WAS DONE LAST
YEAR. GREAT. ANYTHING ELSE YOU
WANT TO ADD? NO. I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR YOUR VOTE. OKAY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. IS THERE
ANYONE ELSE IN THE ROOM HERE
WHO'D LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF SB 1456? HOW ABOUT ANY
OPPOSITION? ALL RIGHT. SEEING
NONE, WE'LL COME BACK TO THE
DÍAS COLLEAGUES. ANYBODY HAVE
ANY COMMENTS? GREAT MOVED BY
SENATOR EGGMAN. SENATOR ROTH,
DID YOU WANT TO CLOSE? JUST
APPRECIATE YOUR. AYE VOTE
MEMBERS. ALL RIGHT, THEN, WE'RE
GOOD TO GO. LET'S TAKE THE ROLL
MOTION. IS THAT THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS BE CONCURRED IN
ASHBY. AYE. ASHBY. AYE. NGUYEN.
ARCHULETA. Ã. ARCHULETA. AYE.
BECKER. DODD. EGGMAN. EGGMAN
AYE. GLAZER. MENGIBAR. NILO.
NILO AYE. ROTH I ROTH I
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS I WILK. AYE. WILK. AYE.
ALL RIGHT. WE'RE GOING TO LEAVE
THE ROLL OPEN FOR JUST A MINUTE
AND SEE IF THERE ARE SOME
STRAGGLERS. BUT BEFORE YOU,
GENERAL, WALK AWAY FROM THAT
PODIUM, I'M NOT SURE IF THIS IS
GOING TO BE OUR LAST HEARING. WE
GOT A COUPLE BMP ITEMS FLOATING
AROUND OR BILLS. I THINK WE HAVE
TWO MORE, SO I THINK WE'LL BE
BACK JUST IN CASE WE'RE NOT,
THOUGH, I DO WANT TO JUST THANK
THIS BPD TEAM. THE STAFF, THE
SERGEANTS, THEY WORK SO HARD.
ALL OF OUR CREW. AND YOU KNOW, I
INHERITED THIS JUST A FEW MONTHS
AGO. THIS IS A REALLY IMPORTANT
COMMITTEE. AND I WILL SHARE THIS
ON THE RECORD. THE DAY THAT I
WAS TOLD I GOT TO BE CHAIR OF
THIS COMMITTEE, THE FIRST WORDS
THAT CAME OUT OF MY MOUTH WERE
BEHIND GENERAL ROTH, ARE YOU
CRAZY? I DON'T KNOW THAT I CAN
LIVE UP TO THAT STANDARD, SO I
WILL TRY. I'LL SPEND THE REST OF
MY TIME IN THIS SEAT TRYING TO
ACHIEVE. SIR, WHAT YOU HAVE DONE
FOR THIS COMMITTEE ON BEHALF OF
THE PEOPLE OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND I THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR COMMITMENT. ALL
RIGHT. THOSE OF YOU THAT VOTED
CAN GO. THAT IS OUR ONLY ITEM. I
WILL HANG OUT AND SEE IF WE HAVE
ANY COLLEAGUES. I'LL GIVE THEM
ABOUT TWO MINUTES AND THEN WE'LL
CLOSE THE ROLL.
ALL RIGHT. ALL RIGHT. WE'RE
GOING TO OPEN THE ROLL HERE. AND
WE'RE GOING TO GO THROUGH IT ONE
TIME. AND THEN WE'RE GOING TO
CLOSE IT OUT OKAY. MOTION IS
THAT THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS BE
CONCURRED IN CURRENT VOTES 7 TO
0. CHAIR VOTING AYE. NGUYEN
BECKER. DODD. AYE. DODD. AYE
GLAZER MENGIBAR. ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR. THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT. WE'RE GOING TO
GO AHEAD AND CLOSE THIS OUT. WE
GOT PLENTY OF VOTES THAT'S GOING
TO MOVE ON 8 TO 0. THAT ITEM IS
OUT. THANK YOU.